avec les années je vais prendre plus de
maturité je pense même si je suis j'en
ai je vais essayer d'aller au plus grand
des sommets quand il est de retour en
équipe de france karim benzema l'enfant
terrible du foot français 2004 première
apparition à la télé il a seulement 16
ans il vient de disputer son premier
match lors du championnat d'europe des
moins de 17 ans au début de la deuxième
mi temps les taxes sp et après on a
laissé aller ce match trois ans plus
tard 2007 première sélection en équipe
de france a contre l'autriche
le jeune attaquant n'a que 19 ans et
côtoie des tauliers comme lilian thuram
ou il sagnol est aujourd'hui de se
retrouver avec eux c'est une fierté quoi
c'est un plaisir c'est depuis depuis
tout petit on rêve de ça et aujourd'hui
on y arrive il est alors l'un des plus
grands espoirs du foot français
mais en 2010 première polémique avec la
ferraille à plusieurs joueurs de
l'équipe de france sont impliqués dont
franck ribéry et karim benzema mis en
examen ce soir pour sollicitation d'une
prostituée mineure
le joueur tient sa ligne de défense il
réfute tout en bloc
benzema est relaxé par la justice le 30
janvier 2014 six mois plus tard il
participe à la coupe du monde au brésil
mais en novembre 2015 nouvelle polémique
celle à faire du chantage à la sextape
la victime
le joueur mathieu valbuena benzema il
soupçonnait d'y être impliqué
mathieu valbuena joueurs de l'équipe de
france enregistre une vidéo intime dans
un cadre privé cette vidéo atterrit dans
les mains de trois maîtres chanteurs qui
demande aux footballeurs de payer sinon
il la diffuse sur internet
valbuena refuse parmi ces trois
individus aujourd'hui écroués l'un est
un proche de karim benzema
il demande à son ami footballeur
d'intervenir directement auprès de
valbuena
suite à cette affaire karim benzema est
évincé de l'équipe nationale le 1er juin
2016 après sa mise à l'écart de l'euro
en france nouveau scandale
interviewé pour le journal sportif
espagnol marca le joueur fait cette
déclaration
deschamps a cédé à la pression d'une
partie raciste de la france
les propos qui suscitent un tollé y
compris dans la classe politique
ce qui a été dit
vous insinuez sur id deschamps est
totalement inacceptable
benzema est aussi écarté de la coupe du
monde 2018 le 18 mai 2021
il a fait son retour en équipe de france
près de six ans après sa dernière
sélection
[Musique]